FTX tried to hide billions of dollars in
fraud and now their xdeo Sam bankman
freed is trying to convince everyone it
was an accident he isn't such a bad guy
he just got in over his head and already
there are Financial commentators like
Kevin O'Leary willing to vouch for him I
just think he's a very interesting
individual over time we'll peel this
onion find out what happened I don't
think that guy has a an evil bone in his
body now it may not surprise you but
Kevin O'Leary is a paid spokesman for
FTX but even unpaid sources have
parroted his claims take for instance
the New York Times They quote SPF saying
he was just distracted and that's why
FTX fell apart quote had I been a bit
more concentrated that would have
allowed me to catch on to what was going
on on the risk side that's right guys if
he only hadn't played League of Legends
he might have noticed he was stealing
customer money now of course the New
York Times was roasted for their
uncritical take on Sam as was Kevin
O'Leary but even respected Financial
journalists that I personally like like
Matt Levine of Bloomberg have recently
floated theories around that maybe this
is fraud but maybe not quote I don't
want to minimize the likelihood of
intentional fraud and theft but I want
to say that the story of FTX also reads
like what would happen if you and a few
College friends set up a gigantic
International Financial exchange your
friends are Traders and Engineers not
accountants and compliance officers
they're running a huge exchange and are
too busy for paperwork they move fast
and break things now stories like that
to me leave me wondering well was this
fraud at all was it just a couple of
college grads who didn't know the value
of an accountant could be either one
right and I want to address this not
because anyone in the media specifically
believes that Sam isn't a fraudster
besides Kevin O'Leary probably because
of course there are plenty of legal
reasons not to explicitly call someone a
fraud but I still think it's relevant to
address these ideas and narratives
either way because you can be certain
this is going to be sbf's defense he may
have been dumb he may have been
negligent he may have made some mistakes
but he isn't a criminal he already came
out and said it once I effed up twice
but instead of mentioning fraud he says
it's because of poor internal labeling
that FTX fell apart which I mislabel
things all the time and in a way that's
a compelling simple explanation don't
attribute to malice what you can
attribute to stupidity or in this case
don't attribute to fraud what you can
attribute to a follicle of 20 year olds
in the Bahamas getting in over their
heads that is basically what he wants
you to believe and so I'm here to answer
that question could it possibly be that
FTX is just a story of negligence well
the short answer is no and the long
answer is hell no since FTX unraveled
I've been speaking to Alameda insiders
FTX insiders even people who called out
FTX months ago like short seller Mark
cohotis and the one thing I'm positive
of after all of it is that Sam is
probably the greatest con man of Our
Generation the only real question I have
is why did it take us so long to find
this out now as I share the evidence
that supports this claim bear in mind
compiling a complete postmortem on FTX
is admittingly difficult a paper
shredder leaves behind better evidence
than Sam bankman fraud sorry I mean
freed well not freed for long he's gonna
probably be in jail soon but until that
sweet day arrives just understand that I
don't have the full story yet nobody
does even the people who have full
access to the back end evidence are
still puzzled in fact the main person
tasked with handling the FTX bankruptcy
process also handled Enron which is the
definition of complicated corporate
fraud so you'd think it'd be no big deal
right nope FTX is worse than inron quote
never in my career have I seen such a
complete failure of corporate controls
not only that he says that everything he
got from SBF in the way of evidence he
has quote no confidence in which uh you
know isn't great this is probably
because a Sam has lied NP it sounds like
everything in his Empire was a mess
allegedly FTX was approving expenses
with quote personalized emojis and that
Sam was communicating with disappearing
messages that were set to Auto delete
after quote a short period of time not
only that Sam encouraged employees to do
the same so understand that we don't
have a full picture of what happened yet
in part because well they deliberately
avoided leaving one and I would actually
point to this as the first piece of
evidence of fraud you don't show up to
the scene of a crime with billions
missing and find out all the evidence is
destroyed and say oh darn maybe they
accidentally torched it no that in of
itself is suspicious and deleting your
text messages and encouraging your
employees to do the same that just
screams that you're hiding something but
even though they didn't leave us much to
go on there's still tons of breadcrumbs
that lead us to the same conclusion for
example take the corporate structure of
FTX in all their subsidiaries we've
talked about this it's incredibly
complicated but I'm supposed to believe
the guy who set this up is the same guy
who didn't know it was wrong for him to
take from one company and steal it uh
isn't this the same guy whose parents
are both compliance lawyers sticklers
for the rules you're telling me that guy
doesn't understand what basic fraud is
incidentally this is actually why Kevin
O'Leary thought this was such a safe bet
I'm a paid spokesperson to uh to FTX and
a shareholder there too and big advocate
for Sam because he has two parents that
are compliance lawyers if there's ever a
place I could be that I'm not going to
get in trouble it's going to be at FTX
yikes and yet even after being defrauded
Kevin says given the chance he'd bet on
Sam again if SPF knocked on your door
again and said look I failed in my last
Venture uh I have a new crypto Adventure
I need money would you back him that's a
great question no one's asked me yet I
think we can all admit you can love him
or hate him given what's happened but he
was one of the most brilliant traders in
the crypto Universe he also built one of
the most robust platforms we used FTX
actively it was a very robust platform
uh that allowed us to get information on
a compliant basis so I really like what
he built would you back him the answer
would be
yes unbelievable I don't understand how
these people can't admit they were
fooled by SBF and just end up making
fools of themselves now there's another
part of this story I want to talk about
which was of course the Revelation that
FTX The Exchange and Alameda research
the trading firm were actually sharing
customer funds and there's been some
talk of well maybe this was just a lack
of compliance or accounting but I want
to suggest to you that SBF was not
lacking anything he purposely and
deliberately profited from the vague
relationship between Alameda and FTX and
the first sign of this was when I spoke
to an Insider at Alameda he told me that
they would often use Insider knowledge
of the coins that were going to be
listed on FTX and then they would go buy
those coins up knowing that it would
pump in price when it was finally listed
in other words an easy profit could be
made this by the way is similar to what
happened on coinbase and three people
were arrested for insider trading in
that case but unlike coinbase they this
wasn't Rogue employees this was Alameda
itself doing this so let me get this
straight if it was criminal when three
individuals did it what does it mean
when an entire organization does it I
even asked the Alameda Insider if they
thought that it was criminal behavior
and they told me quote it was probably
criminal in hindsight yeah you know
about the 2020 of hindsight sometimes
you realize wow that was probably
illegal now this Insider evidence is
actually further validated by public
reports that Alameda research amassed
swaths of tokens ahead of FTX saying it
would list them according to an analysis
of public blockchain data this is from
The Wall Street Journal and it just
corroborates this Insider testimony
there's insider trading going on at
Alameda so do you think someone Sam who
is doing criminal activity is going to
want a bunch of accountants and
compliance people sniffing around no
they're going to want criminals hanging
around them so with that said and
completely unrelated guess who FTX chose
as their Chief regulatory officer this
guy Dan Friedberg now Dan's past is very
important because he used to work for
ultimate bet a poker site which got in a
lot of trouble and has a very shady past
for reasons we've explained before
ultimate bet got in trouble because they
were giving some of their players a god
mode that allowed them to see the other
pokers players cards which would
obviously be an advantage if you're
trying to play poker wow so Friedberg
was working for ultimate bet during
these god mode days and although he was
never charged with anything there is
leaked audio coming out from him
conspiring to hide the owner of ultimate
bet from facing any consequences from
using it here's Russ Hamilton the former
owner of ultimate bet who used god mode
and admits to making money with it
telling Friedberg that he wants to get
out of this cheating scandal I feel and
I and I did take this money and I'm not
trying to make it right Dan so we've got
to get that out of the way right real
quick okay so then Dan Friedberg replies
to Russ that maybe they should just
blame it all on a third party consultant
and say that was who used the god mode
on their website instead of Russ himself
I think to the public it just says
former consultant
albums of a server flaw of hacking in
the clients been able to identify
exactly when
sometimes he played with it sometimes he
played Without
sometimes he intentionally won and
sometimes the intentionally lost
very erratic play
but we've been able to identify at the
times when the Tool was
up and they're not one of these what you
could also say is that the tools were
originally set for a 15-minute delay
and he's hacked it to her
to a real time but that's what we do so
this is the guy they hired at FTX as
their Chief regulatory officer a guy who
once conspired to hide his cheating boss
and of course there are more red flags
about the relationship between FTX and
Alameda you might assume that like okay
if it was negligence maybe everyone
inside the organization was just sharing
information with everyone there was
there was no walls in place right and
that's what created the conflicts of
interest but that doesn't match with
what we've heard I personally have
spoken to FTX insiders who said they
were blindsided by the collapse they
didn't know anything The Wall Street
Journal also reports that FTX employees
were completely in the dark which
corroborates that so FTX employees had
no idea what was going on at Alameda
meanwhile the Alameda employees on the
other hand knew exactly what was going
on at FTX they had backend access so
this relationship wasn't uncontrolled it
was one-sided back to the god mode
analogy it was almost as if they
specifically set up their crypto
exchange to be pill for offered by their
Traders without anyone knowing almost
like they had a back door oh oh yeah
they did end up building a back door I
forgot their CTO built a back door to
avoid triggering red flags see it's hard
to call things like this accidents or
negligence it's literally designed to be
hidden Alameda had a one-way window into
FTX to steal whatever they wanted from
client funds and I do mean steal not
misappropriate not negligently lose
steel but unbelievably the way it's
quoted in like the New York Times you'd
think this was some kind of loan they
took out a margin position it's called
but we know now it wasn't a margin
position Alameda apparently had a secret
exemption from certain aspects of
ftx.com's Auto Liquidation protocol
according to their new CEO so this large
margin position isn't a margin position
at all because they could never be
liquidated and I'm sure Dan Friedberg
might be somewhere on a call trying to
figure out how to blame a rogue employee
on this secret exam attention but let's
be honest with ourselves Alameda knew
what they were doing was criminal that's
why they call it a secret exemption and
they were even willing to lie about it
to keep it a secret Alameda CEO Caroline
Ellison denied special access to
Bloomberg News saying we definitely have
a Chinese wall in terms of information
sharing to ensure that no one at Alameda
would get customer information from FTX
or any sort of special treatment from
FTX but obviously this was a lie here
Sam bankman freed lying too quote
Alameda is a wholly separate entity well
we know that isn't true either looking
back it was obvious because even when
you'd wire the money to FTX the
international wiring instructions were
to Alameda research not exactly separate
and so after finding all of this out I
spoke to Mark cohotis who called out SBF
as a fraud much earlier than almost
anyone else and I asked him his thoughts
and he said this was all obvious a mile
away I knew something was wrong a year
ago because everything this guy said and
you can play all his interviews back
nothing added up you know nothing added
up if people ask me a question I will
give them an answer or say I don't know
I won't talk in a figure eight you know
I won't answer a question with a
non-answer again and again and again
nothing this guy said has ever made a
lick a sense and if he would have come
to my office looking for money I would
have told him to hit the bricks because
nothing added I mean they didn't even
figure out that his accountants address
was somewhere in the metaverse
I mean at a minimum you check out who
the guy's auditor is and say who's your
auditor oh my Auditor's name is is the
Pep Boy Manny Moe and Jack okay what's
his address
somewhere in the metaverse is this a
joke no I'm being serious now I know
what you're thinking surely that can't
be true that the auditor of FTX was
located in the metaverse but checking
their official bankruptcy filings
that is the case and now because no one
looked into it FTX owes 3.1 billion
dollars to its top 50 creditors alone
and I guess if they have complaints they
can go to the metaverse and ask about it
I'm just kidding well kind of I actually
don't think they probably take
complaints in the metaverse either way
the question of was Sam bankman freed a
fraud is not much of a question at all
the real question is why did so few
people catch on early and why didn't the
media catch on sooner I'm not sure we
can speculate maybe it was because of
political donations or this whole story
about effective altruism But ultimately
what I know for sure is that people like
Marco hodis they weren't silent he says
he took it to journalists before the
crash to see if they'd do anything and
they said no I went to Bloomberg with my
pal who I was working on this thing with
and we laid it out to five
crypto five ladies on the crypto team
and they passed and they said it would
be too much work we'd lose access it's
bad for business right they'd hang up on
us if we ask these questions well at
least I had the questions
denied a story with you because they
thought it would lose them access and it
was too much work yes a hundred percent
when when did this happen this happened
in July this happened in early July they
had everything they had everything wow
they they also said But I didn't want
anyone fired I didn't want anyone fired
so I didn't get this they said it was
bad for business I.E advertising you're
kidding so so they admit their conflict
of interest with advertisers in the
crypto space
yes now this is pretty shocking
allegations so I did want to reach out
to Bloomberg for comment to see if they
wanted to respond to this and here's
what they said